this video is sponsored by nordvpn what
if i told you that you can do magic
would you look at me and go
magic's not real
well you're wrong because with nordvpn
you can literally use vpn magic to mask
your ip address why would you do that
you ask great question you do so in
order to access games or servers or
movies and tv shows from out of country
protect your personal payment or login
info online or even block malicious
websites all of which nordvpn makes as
easy as
one click on any device if you are
interested in upgrading your internet
with nordvpn magic then click the link
in the description below to get nord's
exclusive 30 day money back guarantee
and now on to the video
[Music]
hey everyone bandit here ever heard of
the zelda game called ocarina of time
the answer is yes do you remember that
weird cloaked figure with that giant red
eye that only appeared when link was an
adult in the adult timeline not the
child timeline the po hunter or ghost
hunter has for decades been quite the
mystery for those who enjoy delving into
theory territory and actually on that
note there have been lots of conclusions
drawn about just who this purple stick
waver could be there are some who
believe the individual to be the young
child in the graveyard who waves a stick
around and is interested in grave tours
and stuff and that's pretty much the
theory no joke sometimes that's all that
goes into these things another more
believable theory is that the hunter is
none other than the hylian soldier who
previously was standing in this very
spot seven years ago and this is
actually a decently believable theory i
mean that soldier does say some pretty
weird stuff about a lack of troubles in
the world making him bored and that he
likes and studies ghosts tie that into
the po hunter's hunting of pose and his
twisted sense of humor with all the
giggling and the whole you know telling
link he could sell his body from
anything and the triforce symbol on his
clothing and the crudely drawn triforce
on the wall behind him and you've got
yourself a decent zelda theory even
though both of these theories are at
least somewhat believable in their own
right unfortunately neither of them
account for what is perhaps the most
intriguing and recognizable detail of
the poe collector and that is his face
or lack thereof now keep in mind i'm not
saying it's wrong to believe whatever
explanation feels right to you as an
individual after all we wouldn't be
theorizing in the first place if any of
this were confirmed in game thanks for
being vague nintendo with that said
though as i'm sure you predicted i tend
to think a bit differently than the
theories that i presented so far and
it's all because of the po hunter's big
red eye specifically the fact that
there's only one and it's red and it's
glowing i just feel very strongly that
this is the most key identifying detail
to figure out and once we do we can work
backwards from there to draw another
conclusion if you think about it the
only creatures in the entire game that
feature one eye besides the po collector
themselves are all enemies and for some
reason i find it hard to believe that
abimos is just chilling here in the
castle marketplace talking about dead
people and if we search through every
non-enemy character in the game we are
left with a whopping zero personalities
for potential one-eyed creeps i knew it
wasn't going to be this simple so since
we can't just point to another one-eyed
individual for an easy answer let's
widen the search what about symbols are
there symbols in the game that
prominently feature just one central eye
any fan of the legend of zelda will
automatically think of the shika whose
symbol is famously the single eye with a
teardrop and it's the only symbol in the
entire game that could fit the single
eye description too but okay we have a
symbol and a one-eyed hooded figure
what's the connection here well i'm so
glad you asked because there just so
happens to be a mask in the game that
prominently features the one-eyed
sheikah symbol in the faceplate and that
is the mask of truth and masks are worn
on faces so if this individual were to
be wearing the mask of truth with a hood
over it that would explain the red eye
which is as i already mentioned the key
identifying feature of the poe collector
in fact this is probably the only
explanation in the entire game for it
given that the poe collector looks
pretty much like a plain jane human
being otherwise but now we've gotta ask
a couple other questions like why is the
red eye glowing when the mask is not
shown to do that elsewhere and who if
anyone could even have possession of the
mask of truth at this particular point
in time great questions once again let's
start with the glowy bit if you recall
when talking to the happy mask salesman
as a child he will tell you that it's a
mysterious mask passed down by the
sheikh that allows you to see into other
people's minds then he says that it's
scary but you'll understand why when you
grow older which is just a little joke
about how sick people can be when
they're all grown up but it's also a
very telling detail see if you run
around with a mask on as a child you can
talk to gossip stones which previously
you couldn't and get that latest mad
gossip about hyrule but you can't read
people's minds and subsequently the mask
never glows now it could be that the
happy mask salesman while lightheartedly
joking about how scary it is to read
adult minds also literally meant that
the mask's mind-reading powers only
activate when worn by an adult and if
you recall once again when meeting the
po collector for the first time who is
definitely an adult they say to link
that they can in fact quote read
people's minds and they do so by telling
link what his name is before he even
says anything and interestingly enough
the words people's minds only appear
twice in the entire game script here and
when talking to the happy mask salesman
about the mask of truth it's pretty
plausible at this point that what this
all means is that the mask of truth has
the power to read other people's minds
when worn by an adult which would
explain why the poe collector can read
link's mind and it's glowing here but
not here now that we've established that
this is most likely a person wearing the
mask of truth it's time to talk about
the elephant in the room who'll that be
and could it be that this is the soldier
from seven years ago who is now somehow
wearing the mask sure it's possible we
can only speculate on how the soldier
would have happened upon possession of
the mask though on the other hand the
one person who we know for a fact is in
possession of the mask of truth would be
the happy mask salesman himself in fact
it's one of the masks that link can't
sell to anyone but can only borrow
unless the happy mask salesman gave the
mask to the soldier for some unknown
reason at some point within the seven
year gap between timelines this means
that the po collector has to be none
other than the happy mask salesmen i
mean it's not like they're not similar
they both have pretty much the same skin
tone are both skinny adults are both
located in the castletown marketplace
are both vendors both have a strange
sense of humor both wear purple with
gold jewelry and both deal with the
spirits of the dead yeah if you take the
happy mask salesman's appearance from
majora's mask into account then you know
that at least some of the man's masks
actually house ghosts or spirits of the
dead inside them sorry mario and since
he is a collector of these masks is that
not extremely similar to the collector
of pose they also both have another very
interesting connection in their dialogue
with the po collector telling link that
if he earns a thousand points by
collecting and selling lots of pose he
will be a happy man and the happy mask
salesman also tells link that if he
sells all the masks he will become happy
happy is also in the name happy mask
salesman so they definitely have an
alarmingly high amount of similarities
both physically and metaphysically that
seem to prove that they are the same
individual and i mean it's not like it
doesn't make sense the happy mask
salesman wouldn't have been able to
remain in his old shop since it's kind
of missing a roof these days and with
the current state of affairs also known
as the desertion of hyrule castle town
and complete lack of occupants or
potential mask hungry customers perhaps
he donned the mask of truth in order to
see into people's minds and determine if
they are friend or foe and ultimately
gave up the whole mask salesman persona
since there were no peaceful hylians
around to fool anymore and he could just
call it what it is that he's marketing
now pose souls now i can tell some of
you are already thinking aha
got him there's no way it could be the
happy mask salesman because the happy
mask salesman goes off on his own
journey in the child timeline leading to
the events of majora's mask before the
adult timeline so that can't be him
right here and that's a good point
however i'd say that the very fact that
the masked salesman goes off to termina
prior to majora's mask is proof that he
probably remained in hyrule after
ganondorf took control in ocarina of
time and here's why if the happy mask
salesman is the po collector take a
listen to one other thing he says he
calls ganondorf the great ganondorf and
says that it's a great time for the po
business why because ganondorf and his
monsters have killed lots of people and
therefore created lots of lingering
ghosts pose but after link defeats
ganondorf at the end of the adult
timeline and gets sent back to the new
child timeline and warns the hylian
crown about the dangers of ganondorf the
king of thieves is banished to the
twilight realm after some technical
difficulties and it is only then in this
new child timeline that the happy mask
salesman leaves hyrule in the events of
majora's mask transpire why because he's
looking to be in the presence of someone
he considers great someone who brings
with them lots of death he's looking for
a place to do business i mean what else
would be the catalyst for him to leave
in the child timeline if not ganondorf's
banishment and listen the guy's messed
up okay he's got a very dark side to him
he can flip his mood on a switch he
deals with the souls of the dead and he
may not even be from this planet and
he's in possession of one of the darkest
and most evil relics in the entire
series so yeah i think that if the great
ganondorf remained in hyrule then so did
the happy mask salesman the poe
collector but this is all just my theory
it doesn't account for the alternate
universe appearance of the poe collector
in majora's mask although the similar
appearance could just be a coincidence
since the dev team had to reuse lots of
models from ocarina of time because of
the short development time and it could
even still be the happy mask salesman or
even one of his kin from the moon but
that is an entire other theory what do
you guys think is the poe collector the
bored soldier who said some pretty weird
stuff seven years ago or is it the happy
mask salesman for any of the reasons
brought up in this video let me know in
the comments below also thank you so
much for watching please consider liking
the video if you enjoyed it which helps
a lot on the algorithm and subscribe to
stick around if you haven't already
especially so that you won't be confused
in the coming weeks as a quick update
for those of you who may have missed my
previous video or who may be new to the
channel there's a pretty major change
coming i'm going to be rebranding the
name of this channel from masking
abandon to bandit games which is
something that i've been thinking about
for a long time if you'd like more
details as to why i chose to do this
check out my previous video which will
be linked in the description below but
either way make sure you subscribe so
that the channel's new name doesn't miss
your notifications also huge thanks to
my bandit crew of which i have another
new name to announce say hello to weezer
who joined at the trickster level thank
you guys so much you're literally what
keeps me going with the channel and
pushes me to try to go big or go home
and that's all i've got for this one so
as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
you